the little tasks that you've just done
um a ken ken puzzle
uh i have been known to give this
to students in classes sometimes
just for the lols like it's just a fun
puzzle and so for the many of you who've
never seen one of this before
actually just i got it sort of
inconsistently can you please raise your
hand
if this morning was the first time
you've ever seen or attempted one of
these before hands up straight
i just want to get a quick look wow
wow okay thank you hands out all right
so um
these are great i hope i've just um
introduced you to a world you'll get to
enjoy exploring in the future
but there was this time a real
functional
reason why uh we had to go with this but
that reason will become clearer
a little bit later on so just um just
file it away for one moment
congratulations you made it 2020 is over
you officially survived
and thank you for all of you being here
you know 7 30
day one it's um it's genuinely
appreciated day zero someone
some people call it like is this a real
day um or is for us
we're starting a new topic today and i
hope you're excited about that
to introduce that topic i have a
question for all of you that i want you
to actually consider
um at the tables where you are and i
want you to potentially you know write
down some thoughts on this
maybe just a word or two a key sentence
here's the question
you all do a lot of maths like you spend
a significant amount of time
studying this subject but you also study
other subjects obviously you all study
english
several you study sciences or some of
the you know hsie subjects
the theme that i want to pose to all of
you right now the question i'd love you
to i'm going to give you a couple
minutes to discuss it is
what is it about this subject that makes
it unique
like what is it that makes mathematics
as a discipline
special now i'm going to anticipate your
first answer
maybe it's not your first answer maybe
this is just me being like a bit
pessimistic but i'm going to anticipate
your first answer and tell you
um that it's not true and why some of
you gonna say
mathematics is the subject of numbers
right that's i think that's where it
starts like you can start doing
calculations and arithmetic and then
algebra and all the rest
can someone tell me why numbers are not
the thing that makes
mathematics unique yeah go ahead it's
all about
okay so number one there are other
things included like that's not the only
thing
um that's true but i want you to like
i'm trying to make a point of comparison
with the other subjects
like just think for a second especially
if you're a science student but really
in any of the other subjects
why is it that mathematics can't claim
numbers as its unique thing
come on it's not a it's not a rhetorical
question it's a really like don't don't
overthink it it's really obvious out
there
numbers exist in sciences as well but
mathematics is about problem solving
oh okay so you're starting to get into
what i'm gonna ask you to discuss but
you've gotten at the heart of it right
sure we're we love numbers and we're
surrounded by but
literally every other subject even a
subject like english if you studied
rhythm
and rhyme and poetry every other subject
has numbers too
so numbers are not the thing that makes
mathematics unique
i'm going to give you a couple minutes
to have a think turn write something
down
anything and then we'll come back and
discuss all right
so uh we could we could play this game
for quite some time
uh which i hope you've been enjoying
i've been i've been slightly unfair
um in that there are many many different
answers to this question that are all
valid
but i'd love to hear as succinct as you
can maybe a word or a short sentence
uh what are your takes on this friend
can i put you on the spot
you've got several answers actually
which is part why i'm putting on this
one give us one give us one
it's universal it's universal can you
even though i asked for a short answer
can you unpack what you mean by
mathematics is universal um i don't know
even if you're like
some different alien species right
people like synthetic things
stand out beyond the beating things
that's what they're called
they they give a binary and
this is our accounting system so that
other species if they exist
or no okay they can tap too so it's a
thing that
every species can do yeah nice i really
like that so you're thinking of
potentially i don't know if you guys
know this because a long time ago
uh the voyager space probes so the
voyage of one or i don't know if it's
one or two but it's the fastest
moving human object in history because
just been accelerating out of the solar
system for
decades at the moment and on it there
are these uh
this kind of record of if some alien
happens upon these things
what can we show to communicate we have
intelligence and that kind of thing and
a lot of it is mathematics
now it is worth pointing out there's
some other cultural stuff on there
there's like music
there's you know written language but as
fairly pointed out those are not
universal um even within our own planet
right you go to another country and it's
like i can't read that
english what is that that's not
universal to me someone want to give us
a very different answer who's got
something else
here you go here jeff oh it's strictly
logical
it's strictly logical what do you mean
by that okay
so like whenever equations gonna be a
equal to
b equals the c then therefore a equals
to c right
something like that there's no you know
yeah okay sure all right so there's
there's a lot of interesting ideas there
that you know there's this idea of logic
that we don't guess
uh we can sort of string together an
argument that's uh
quite different to other arguments in
other subjects right um i'll return to
that idea does anyone want to give
one last suggestion someone had
something different to either of those
ideas
anyone
keep thinking please as promised there
are many other good answers to this but
um i'm actually going to take zhao's as
a touch point because i think it sort of
gets it what is special about this topic
that we're about to introduce today
um and the angle on maths that i want to
take okay
uh in all your different subjects you
learn stuff right
that's kind of the point like i learn
about texts in english i learnt about
periods of history i learned about how
biology works etc right
so you gain knowledge and skills but
this is the important idea
the nature of how we know things in
mathematics is
completely different and unique among
all the different subjects there's a way
in which every other subject is the same
and mathematics kind of stands off on
its own so
to give you a sense of what i mean by
that i'm just going to give you a bit of
a comparison right
hands up who studies the science it's
almost all of you isn't it
it's almost all of you okay thank you
hands down so
non-rhetorical question how do we know
things are true
how do we know what is reality
in science what's the method that we use
experiments
we use experiments yeah we use
experiments when we experiment what do
we
like if you experimented once and said
oh look this thing happens is that
enough
to know something is true in science
it's not right what do we have to do
after that
yeah we have to um there's this idea
called repeatability right
uh we can actually get that result and
get it over and over again we can get on
different situations circumstances and
so on
so we observe we experiment and we
importantly we do it over and over again
so the large hadron collider i don't
know who the physics students are right
one of the big things behind it is it's
not just
colliding particles together hadrons
protons etc
real fast it's doing it millions of
times
per second so that we can know with
great confidence
this doesn't just happen once or a
thousand times or a million times
it happens you know orders of magnitude
more and that's how we know things are
true
in science but you can't do that in
history can you
right you can't by its nature you can't
repeat things in history so
how do we know things you still we can
still establish that things are reality
historically how do we do it though we
don't do it by experimentation at all
sure you've given us a good thought
already so i wonder if anyone else is
willing
to share a record record so we i mean i
kind of gave you a bit of a clue right
we look at we generally call them
sources do you remember that's a special
name right um and then we analyze those
sources and those are often like
archaeological records or written things
and we try and come up with a story a
narrative that makes sense of all those
different sources
right because sources often disagree but
we can look at all of them together and
say well
even though they have different
perspectives we can come up with one
picture that makes sense of all the
different
ones okay all right so now
this is where we're getting the heart of
things right in mathematics it's not
enough
to just have like how do we true how do
we prove that say
pythagoras theorem was true how do we
know is true answer
we did not just draw lots and lots of
triangles and
measure hypotenuses and all that kind of
thing we that wouldn't have been enough
you could have a billion triangles and
say oh it's all true but
that would not be enough in mathematical
terms
um we don't trust sources either i mean
we do have sources
but that's not the reason why we're like
oh some guy isaac newton wrote this down
one time so we're like
he seems legit that's not how we do it
in maths how do we do it
xiao actually had the word right what
was where starts with an l
it's logic right um importantly it's
deductive
logic like sherlock holmes type stuff
right if this is true then this is true
and if that's true then this is true and
you've been doing this for years and
years
and years right now importantly this is
why i gave you that task right this is
how
even if you couldn't articulate it this
is how you solve the kencam
right have a think about for example uh
let's look at that blue cage you can see
it you've probably it was probably one
of the first ones you filled in is my
guess right
uh we knew we only had the numbers one
two three and four to play with
right but you pretty quickly determined
what were the numbers that went in there
from left to right it's a three
and then a one and then a three yeah now
how did you know
how did you know that it had to be a
three one and a three
any takers come on have a look i i know
most of you have it written yeah go
ahead
yeah that's right so we could because
you've got very few combinations you can
actually just
process in your mind you're like i've
got one two three and four right
the two and the four are dots aren't
they because they're even numbers
and nine's an odd number when you
multiply even numbers you'll get more
even numbers
so like i've only got the one and the
three to play with but then you knew
their position
right how did i know it couldn't be like
one three three for instance
yeah then they're in a column or they're
in a row so that's how you know they're
separated out right
so you can you see the mechanics of how
we're thinking this through we're
employing
deductive logic now deductive logic
is really really special because unlike
scientific and historical knowledge
it's timeless there's not going to be
someone who comes along and does an
experiment one day and it's like oh
actually we got we had better
instruments so we learned
that it wasn't a 313 because we're like
oh we can we can see better now
our experimentation is better quality we
do this in science all the time that's
kind of the point
right it's like oh we thought an atom
looked like this we thought it was like
plum pudding and then we thought it was
like a
a solar system with things all around
they were like no those are wrong we
have better instruments now right
but this doesn't happen in mathematics
things
are logically true so they're timelessly
true does this make sense
and this deductive logic is what we're
going to go through in our new topic
this term uh it's called the nature of
proof
uh this is the code in the syllabus
because we've encouraged you guys to
look at the syllabus and go through it
as we go through it
it's a much shorter topic than complex
numbers actually the complex numbers we
did last term were kind of two
different topics that we sort of jammed
together but even though it's a short
topic
i think you're going to find it is
dramatically different to every other
thing you've done in mathematics even
though it's right at the core of it okay
so to get your hands dirty okay because
i've already been talking to you
uncomfortably long i'm going to give you
an example of the kind of thing we're
going to be wrestling with
in this topic okay and this is a very
classic kind of puzzle
that you're going to spend uh five or
ten minutes doing okay depending on how
quickly you solve it
so there's this island okay i mean you
may like to jot some of this down by the
way because i haven't given you a piece
of paper for it
um there's this island and there are
only two kinds of people on this island
liars truth tellers lies lie truth
tellers
tell truth okay so there's the setup
and then you meet three people
and they say these things to you i'm not
going to read them out because you can
read them out yourselves
the question to all of you and i'm going
to invite you
to spend some time on this first just in
the quiet of your own brain so we're
going to have a silent room for a minute
or two
and then i'm going to get you to work
together the question for all of you is
on this evidence and this setup who's
who
who's lying who's telling the truth
you've
seen you've heard of puzzles like this
before right lateral thinking puzzles
one or two minutes i'll give you a heads
up and i'll let you know can i ask you
to jot down a few things
see if you can unravel who is who and
what's going on here
and then i'll prompt you to then compare
thoughts and start arguing with each
other
off you go